right now you might be watching this
video distracting yourself from those
emails you said you'd get around to
doing and perhaps later you feel guilty
for your lack of focus well don't beat
yourself up too much there's a
scientific reason for your
distractibility
a study carried out by scientists at
Princeton University and the University
of california-berkeley concluded that
our brains refocus our attention four
times every single second
well our brains have limited processing
resources meaning that we can't
simultaneously process all the
information in our complex environment
at the highest level instead the brain
has developed a collection of mechanisms
that determine which aspects of the
embark environment should receive
preferential processing and this
collection of mechanisms is referred to
as attention my name is Ian feeble corn
I'm a neuroscientist at Princeton
University the mechanism of attention
that is most often studied is spatial
attention where we boost the processing
of a specific location that's the
process our brains go through when we
for example walk into a room at a party
there's an enormous amount of
information in the space lots of people
their faces clothing where they're
standing the list is endless
we are phenomenally good at processing
this data but not all at once our brain
sifts this information into levels of
importance what we need to know now what
can wait till later and what can be
dismissed entirely spatial attention has
often been compared to a spotlight that
continuously scans the environment
stopping or pausing to illuminate
behaviorally relevant aspects of the
environment or locations the classic
view of spatial attention are this
metaphorical spotlight is that it the
strength of that's what spotlight is
continuous
however our work has shown that instead
the spotlight seems to be dimming four
times per second so when we think we're
giving something elf full attention
we're still distractible almost
constantly and so the question is why
would that be
we've proposed that this dimming of our
metaphorical spotlight prevents us from
becoming overly focused on any single
location in the environment it provides
these windows of opportunity when it's
easier to disengage from the presently
attended location and shift our
attention to another location or aspect
of the environment there is a network of
brain regions that directs this
metaphorical spotlight of spatial
attention within this network there's
what we refer to as neural oscillations
and so basically it's like a sine wave
right there are peaks and there are
troughs and you can conceptualize these
sine waves in your brain or these you
know just it's just a wave right the
peaks of that are like high excitability
States that means that the neurons are
really ready to fire and so if a visual
stimulus happens to occur at that peak
when the neurons are ready to fire
you're more likely to detect that visual
stimulus and if it happens instead at a
trough where the neurons are less ready
to fire you're more likely to miss that
stimulus
the study shows for the first time that
our brains are constantly alternating
between two different states one that is
associated with focus and one that's
associated with distractibility through
our evolution again you could see how
this could but it could be to our
advantage right in a survival mode where
you're you're out foraging there might
be a predator and you don't want to miss
that predator because you're overly
focused on the task at hand but in a
modern office environment those
distractions aren't critical to your
survival they're just keeping you from
being able to focus on something you
need to do and so something that helped
us the revolution could be hurting us in
another context in both our work and
personal lives various technologies are
vying for our attention and the current
pandemic has only made this more
apparent in order to do our jobs and
continue an active social life we rely
on these devices more than ever
the very thing that was designed to aid
our productivity is in fact doing the
opposite and that's no accident so how
have companies optimized products to
take advantage of our inherent
distractibility of course when it comes
to our technology the same mechanic of
on a slot machine in a casino is also at
work when it comes to scrolling a feed
it's the same exact psychology of a
variable reward this is near al he's a
behavioral designer and best-selling
author his 2013 book hooked advised
companies how to make habit-forming
products six years later he released
indestructible which offers a way for
those of us who found themselves
habitually using a product to take back
control today because of the data that
is being collected on us as we use these
tools we are manufacturing the products
in real time based on the data we give
these companies you are investing in the
service giving it data to customize the
experience just for you
for the first time products no longer
depreciate you think about it when when
a consumer buys a product that product
loses value with with usage with wear
and tear it depreciates but
habit-forming products should do the
opposite
they actually appreciate because they
store value the more they are used so if
you think the world is distracting today
just wait a few years this trend is not
reversing these tools are here to stay
and if anything the world will become a
more distracting place in the years to
come as we have the confluence of more
data transmitted at faster speeds and
greater accessibility to these tools
that means that if you are looking for
distraction than distraction you will
find so if there's one thing I want
people to remember when it comes to
distraction it's that the antidote to
impulsiveness is forethought so if you
have the chocolate cake on the fork and
it's on its way to your mouth it's too
late if you're about to take a puff of
that cigarette and the cigarette is lit
in your hand
you've lost if you're sleeping next to
your cellphone inches from your bed
they're gonna get you because it's too
late however there's no algorithm
there's no consumer psychology principle
there's nothing that these products can
do that can't be prevented with taking
steps in advance
simple things like turning off
notifications which 2/3 of people with a
smart phone never do things like
changing our desktop on our computer to
make sure that there's less distraction
on our devices things like changing
distraction in the workplace we know
that as much as we blame technology for
distracting us one of the greatest
sources of distraction in the workplace
is the open floor plan office so
acknowledging the fact that distraction
has been around forever and that people
have been getting distracted well before
these modern tech tools indicates to us
that the source of the distraction is
not the technology that's simply the
proximal cause that's the symptom not
the root cause the real cause of
distraction is that most distraction
starts from within us and our desire to
escape an uncomfortable sensation like
boredom anxiety uncertainty stress
fatigue this is the real source of
distraction and if we don't tackle
what's called the internal triggers we
will always find distraction somewhere